[Music]
this is the year of the quad since the
last Olympic Games snowboarders and
skiers have perfected a trick called the
quad court which looks and sounds
ridiculous because it is it's five full
spins and for full flips all in the span
of about three seconds but you know who
spins a lot faster than that in way less
time figure skaters we're gonna find out
what it takes to spin your body four
times in the air in a fraction of a
second and why spending five times could
be almost impossible
three years ago British snowboarder
Billy Morgan pulled off the world's
first quad cork Morgan will be at the
Olympics as will Andre raggedly who last
year became the first person to do a
quad cork on skis mind you these are
some of the world's best athletes rigged
at leas crazy parkour workout went viral
this fall because it's like a superhuman
Rube Goldberg in the gym but only a few
years ago skiers and snowboarders
weren't even sure the quad cork was
possible which raises an interesting
question are we at the limit of how much
a human can turn and flip through the
air as amazing as the quad cork is it
might not be the limit one physicist
calculated that a border could actually
complete six or more cork screws that's
because snowboarders and skiers get hang
times of close to three seconds that may
not sound like much but it is a lot of
time - a figure skater like 16 year-old
dent Ron
he's an up-and-coming skater in San
Francisco he took home the silver at
Junior Nationals this year so you're
here today to practice quads right yeah
yeah yeah try yeah yeah
emphasis on Trey yeah
but getting that quad down perfect is
tough Dinn and other skaters don't get a
ramp to launch fraud they have only
their leg muscles to propel them about a
foot and a half off the ice and then
they've got just about six tenths of a
second to rotate and land it it's one
really big fast motion so you jump up in
the air and then you kind of pull your
arms in and your legs at the same time
if you've ever seen a skater spin you've
got the idea they start with their arms
extended and as they pull their arms in
it causes the rotation to speed up same
thing when they're in the air that's
because it's something called the
conservation of angular momentum angular
momentum depends on both the speed of
the skaters rotation and the position of
the skaters body relative to the axis
that's the center of their rotation the
closer the body parts are to the axis of
rotation the faster they spin and then
of course is the landing or you have to
over them before you make contact with
the ice which a softer rotation is a
definite landing quads have become
pretty much mandatory for the top male
skaters thanks in part to u.s. national
champion Nathan Chen the first man to
land five of them in one program to get
a better sense of what it takes I
bounced with an Olympic skater got
insanely dizzy on this thing and talked
revolutions per minute with this guy
would with the United States figure
skating to assist coaches and skaters in
performing multiple revolution jumps
Richards is a professor of kinesiology
and he uses motion capture technology to
map jumps and help correct slight
imbalances that can throw off even
elites to learn what that kind of
rotation feels like I got some help from
Tim Gable he was the first American to
land a quad in competition and did three
of them on his way to a bronze medal at
the 2002 Olympics they called him the
quad king you're actually known as the
quad King right
I was the quad king until Nathan Chen
came along and unseated me so what did
it take to become the quad king I think
it took a lack of fear and probably a
little stupidity and some time on the
trampoline which skaters use to practice
their jumps I mean you've got more hang
time on a trampoline you can experiment
with the technique and the air position
a little bit more with a lot less wear
and tear on your body I'm all about less
wear and tear on the body so just one
easy turn and Gable made it look pretty
easy but for me
a totally different story Tim gave me a
lot of pointers on how to engage my core
and spin more efficiently right arm is
out when I was out core is engaged and
[Music]
alright well done my friend three to go
I asked him to tie me while I went for
my magnificent spin and a half and 1.08
well you've got enough hang time to
successfully complete a quad that's
impressive
even after dozens of jumps I never made
it to even revolutions much less for one
of the reasons to train on a trampoline
is that ice skating for all its grace is
a brutal sport researchers at Brigham
Young University actually attached
sensors to skates to record the impact
forces of landing big jumps from the
blade we found that skaters land with
somewhere between five to eight times
their body weight even on the safety of
a trampoline there was no way I was ever
gonna pull off a quad like the elite
skaters if I couldn't spin faster to
pull off a Quint would involve even
faster speeds so fast that Richards
doesn't really think they're possible so
you remember how pulling your arms in
can actually make you spin faster
there's a way to practice that at home
it's with one of these things it's
called a gold medal Pro spin trainer and
it's basically a human turntable it is
per the instructions for serious skaters
so naturally I tried practicing with it
and basically just made myself sick then
I brought it into work for my co-workers
to try
pretty sure none of us got anywhere
close to hitting 400 y'all felt that way
but there might be a way for
professionals to get the speeds they
need to do a Quint and that's what these
they're weighted glutes and in an
experiment Sara Ridge and Jim Richards
had athletes wear them while performing
jumps minutes I'm going to show you why
from the safety this chair so if you
have a greater amount of angular
momentum because your arms were out wide
and because you had an extra mass
further away from your axis of rotation
once you're in the air and you bring
your arms in that extra mass is that
close to your axis rotation all that's
left is you're going to increase your
rotation speed and it works kind of at
least for the first few jumps all of the
skaters were over rotated which meant
that the gloves are doing their job but
after a few more jumps all of the
skaters adapted back to spinning the way
they did before the gloves but even if
skaters could learn to use the way to
their advantage there's no guarantee
that it would be enough to spin them
around five times let alone that it
would be legal so we're probably not
gonna see a Quint any time soon and it's
hard to see why spinning is absurdly
difficult even on a trampoline getting
twice the air that the pros get I can
barely do it one and a half times and it
looked terrible spinning even a little
bit made me feel nauseous and I never
even tried it out on the ice because
this place would not let me so at this
year's games when you see people
spinning and they make it look really
easy remember that it really really is
not
in fact it's right at the edge of what
is humanly possible
[Music]